le 4 août 2020 restera à jamais gravé
dans ces chaînes chadi reese a eu 350
points de suture on le voit ici au pied
du bureau vitré où il se trouvait et
will fils naît le soir de l'explosion
voici ce qu'il a vécu il ne compte plus
les séances pour enlever les morceaux de
verre il y en a encore pour des années
selon ses médecins
je n'ai cette détresse psychologique
près d'un adulte sur deux la ressent
encore un an plus tard selon un rapport
de l'unicef
la photographe saïd et jabra voulait
déjà émigré au canada
l'explosion a tout précipité on voulait
donner encore une chance
et encore une autre chance et encore une
chance et et le jour où l'explosion
s'est passé leucate aude 2020 c'est là
qu'on a décidé que
on peut plus vivre dans un pays où on
appris de sécurité pour le long et même
pour les enfants elle se rappelle la
veille de son départ fin août
j'étais au port j'étais en train de
pleurnicher lava je me suis dit comment
je vais quitter ce pays
ils ont déchiré nos coeurs ils ont
détruit un travail mené on en trouve ce
chapelet de rêve
ils ce sont les responsables politiques
libanais qui ont permis le stockage du
nitrate meurtrier leur impunité mise en
évidence dans un rapport de l'organisme
human rights watch ajoute la colère au
traumatisme sans avancée judiciaire au
liban les avocats tentent d'autres
pistes et d'intenter des procès par
exemple en france pour les
ressortissants français qui ont été
affectés et au canada entre autres pour
des ressortissants canadiens dont la
jeune alexandre najjar qui a des trois
ans et qui a été tué dans l'explosion
qu'il se soit écoulée une année sans
réponse djoko autant là bas que dans la
diaspora et ses énormités de l'ap unités
de l'injustice de et aucun procès ce
sentiment d'impuissance et d'injustice
est très violent très violent
elle est ici depuis trois décennies et
la conjonction de cette catastrophe avec
la pandémie encore compliquer les choses
avant on partait aussi très souvent au
liban là des sports à retourner au pays
pour réinjecter de l'argent pour re
faire rouler l'économie elle autorise la
pandémie à bousiller tout ça donc il ya
eu un monde où les gens ne partait plus
est sur place la situation s'est
dégradée rapidement
la monnaie a perdu 90% de sa valeur
les libanais vivent avec les pénuries
d'électricité d'essence de médicaments
la rage est palpable mais se
transformera-t-elle en une nouvelle
révolution
on passe tellement de temps à s'assurer
qu'on survit on a rarement le temps de
voir plus loin et d'essayer de penser
révolution autres ils nous ont vraiment
nous sommes comme les souris dans un
labyrinthe en train de chercher la
sortie on n'a pas le temps de lever le
nez et voir plus loin saïd et elle va
exposer ses photos à montréal au profit
des libanais quand achats dit il
aimerait suivre le même chemin dieu m'a
donné de chance de vivre comme cela que
je veux pas la vivre dans ce pays est
chaotique du ruban nouvelle vie dans un
pays paisible est sûre il
si mathieu prost radio canada montréal